welcome to the bee no I'm Joe guys I
hear the show love videogames I think
some of you may know that but I want to
take a moment here to shed a spotlight
on some lesser known games that I
thought you might want to know about
because I don't know if you know this
here the Pete Holmes show we do have all
the games
first up middle aged Mutant Ninja
Turtles
yeah in this game they fight high
cholesterol their doctor just like a
crazy question Donatello um have you
been eating exclusively pizza
up next some video game fans might
recognize this as a part of the Marvel
vs. Capcom sort of trend now we have
Marvel vs. Seinfeld which is Wonder Man
Wolverine is not Manimal he's a man got
Mel bonds will read nothing I'm out of
bounds
Wolverine got soft animal bones baby
next for the brand-new Xbox one
they have pong no improvements edition
don't mess with a classic that's what I
say next up we have one for the ladies
it's Q Burt Reynolds okay why does it
feel so right it feels has this been
haunting my dreams that looks so
familiar
forget about tall dark and handsome how
about short orange and incredibly
handsome next up we have from the
Wolfenstein games we now have the
Wolfenstein of Wall Street 3d the
power-ups are cocaine and the power
downs are quaaludes that makes it's not
real here either also in the same genre
of games we now have Wolf Blitzer Steam
3d that's a good one
Wolf Blitzer attack
and from the makers at the classic game
Galaga comes the sequel nobody wanted
Gallagher that's right we did we managed
to merge an obscure 80s references op of
another obscure 80s references they said
it couldn't be done and next from the
Lego family of games we have Lego Dallas
buyers club got to go down to Lego
Mexico get my lego medicine and
obviously as a kid you love Donkey Kong
now they have a full-grown adult version
you're gonna love it donkey dong
everybody does okay
why blur it
you can see it just looks 8-bit now why
does he throw that at Mario and that's
how the games everybody